nos piden dividir x al cubo 5 x 4 entre
x al cuadrado menos x + 1 muy bien
déjame reescribir esta expresión así
como fracción entonces en el numerador
tenemos x al cubo más 5 x menos 4 y en
el denominador nos queda x al cuadrado
ahorita lo pongo x al cuadrado menos x +
1 muy bien esta es una segunda forma de
escribirlo pero la forma que nos va a
ayudar para hacer la división larga es
pues ponerlo por aquí con todo y su
casita entonces estamos dividiendo entre
x al cuadrado menos x más 1 la expresión
la expresión x al cubo x al cubo + + 5 x
a pero ojo aquí no tenemos término
cuadrática entonces déjame poner un
espacio para indicar que ahí va el
término cuadrática aunque no lo tengamos
porque va a ser útil aprovechar este
espacio cuando aparezcan términos
cuadráticas entonces más espacio más 5 x
más 5 x menos 4 menos 4 va entonces
dejamos un espacio para los términos
cuadra ticos ahora sí vamos a hacer la
división larga entonces el término de
mayor grado aquí es x al cuadrado y aquí
es x al cubo cuántas veces cabe x al
cuadrado en x al cubo pues vamos a hacer
la división x al cubo entre x al
cuadrado es igual a x a la 3 menos dos
usando leyes de los exponentes que es
igual x a la 1 que es igual a x entonces
x al cuadrado cabe x veces en x al cubo
aquí ponemos x
vamos a realizar la multiplicación x por
este trinomio y lo ponemos aquí abajo x
por x al cuadrado es x cúbico x cúbica x
x menos x es menos x al cuadrado viste
esta padre tener el espacio de cuadrados
x x 1 es x x y ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es restar tenemos que restar esta
expresión entonces pues bueno restar una
expresión es lo mismo que cambiar el
signo a cada uno de sus términos voy a
hacer eso voy a ponerle aquí menos aquí
más y aquí menos va
entonces restamos a ver cuánto nos queda
x al cubo menos x al cubo se cancela
este con x cuadrada queda x cuadrada
aquí no había nada 5 x x 5 x x es 4 x +
4 x y finalmente este 4 baja no le
estamos restando nada entonces baja como
menos 4 muy bien ahora cuántas veces
cabe x cuadrada en x cuadrada a pues es
esta fácil verdad ni siquiera tenemos
que copiar lo deja de tomar este otro
color verde entonces cabe una vez x
cuadrada cabe una vez en x cuadrada
entonces le pongo aquí 1 ahora qué
hacemos multiplicamos por 11 x x
cuadrado es x cuadrada 1 x - x es menos
x y uno por uno es 1
tenemos que restar entonces le cambiamos
el signo a cada uno de estos menos +
menos y este con este se cancelan 4 x
con x nos queda 5x y menos 4 menos uno
es menos 5 ahora podrías tener la
tentación de seguir dividiendo pero ya
no se va a poder porque porque ahora el
el término de aquí afuera tiene mayor
grado que el de aquí adentro entonces si
x al cuadrado ya no cabe ninguna vez en
5 x 5 así que a esta expresión a esta
expresión que sobra le llamamos el
residuo residuo
persigo vale déjame reescribir esto en
términos de fracción entonces lo que
acabamos de encontrar es que x al cubo
más 5 x menos 4 entre x al cuadrado
menos x más uno es igual a x más 1 x más
1 pero sobraron 5 x 55 x menos menos 5 /
/ / x al cuadrado menos x +
entonces aquí tuviéramos un término
cuadrática podríamos seguir dividiendo
pero como ya no a esto de aquí le
llamamos el residuo vale bueno entonces
voy a volver a copiar esta respuesta de
este lado es x + 1 x 1 + 5 x menos 5
dividido
/ x cuadrada menos x + 1 y ya nada más
para terminar vamos a verificar que en
efecto esta respuesta es correcta cómo
le hacemos para verificar pues
multiplicamos por x cuadrada menos x + 1
déjame multiplicar por x cuadrada x
cuadrada menos x + 1 y el chiste es que
tenemos que volver a llegar a este
trinomio vale vamos a ver si sí o si no
entonces para realizar esta
multiplicación voy a usar la ley
distributiva voy a usar este con este
bueno multiplicar este con este este con
este y luego este con este y vamos a ver
que nos queda entonces empezamos con x
cuadrada x x bueno perdón este este
término x x todo el trinomio entonces
que nos quedaría pues sería x cuadrada x
x
x cúbica luego menos x x x - x cuadrada
luego 1 x x mas x entonces eso es x esta
x vamos con este 1 entonces con este 1
que nos queda
x cuadrada por 1 es x cuadrada a pues
está fácil verdad multiplicar por 1 - x
por 1 es menos x uno por uno es uno muy
bien y ahora vamos a multiplicar este
con este pero bueno sería muy latosos
multiplicar esto por el numerador más
bien el paso clave aquí es darse cuenta
que el el denominador de este es esta
misma expresión entonces este este se va
a cancelar con este y simplemente nos
queda más 5 x más 5 x menos 5 entonces
queda nada más este de acá el numerador
muy bien vamos a simplificar entonces
simplificando tenemos un término de
orden cúbico que es x al cubo al cubo y
ya no hay ningún otro luego tenemos los
cuadra ticos este menos x al cuadrado
con este x al cuadrado se cancelan y nos
queda nos queda pues nada más verdad ya
no nos queda nada más cuadrática ahora
vamos con los términos lineales x con
menos x también se cancelan y todavía
que de este término lineal el 5x más 5x
y finalmente vamos con los términos de
grado cero o las constantes pues que
sería 15 es menos 4 menos 4 y b quedó x
al cubo más 5 x 4 que es exactamente lo
mismo que esto de acá